ihre Nummer ein Single die läuft im
Radio immer noch rauf und runter i like
ist schon fast zwei Jahre alt aber carri
Hilson legt jetzt nach mit pretty girl
Rock und sie kommt nach Deutschland und
sie kommt zu klickzoom und das ist
wieder für euch die einmalige
Gelegenheit dem amerikanischen Superstar
eure Fragen zu stellen und ihr könnt es
hoffentlich rauf und runter beten wenn
ich so die letzten Fragen gesehen habe
dann habt ihr es wirklich intos da waren
einige sehr witzige Sachen dabei also
wenn es ebenso witzig also kreativ ist
wenn ihr den Infotext unten lest und
euch den einen oder anderen Link mal
anschaut und wenn ihr videofragen stellt
dann habt ihr eigentlich die aller
allerbesten Chancen auch dranzukomen ich
drück die
Daumen